are you garbage if your tux has a stain
on it and you wear it anyway then when
you get to the wedding you immediately
spill something on yourself in front of
a crowd to make it look like it happened
there so everybody is nonetheless
I respect the move what
are you doing off
he gets there someone get me meatballs
Dan get your tickets for all the cities
on the stay trashy tour and are you
garbage.com gang before we get the
episode started let's talk about our
good friends at mint mobile
saving you money you didn't even realize
okay I'm talking plants that start at
just 15 bucks a month as we all know
inflation is everywhere thankfully mint
mobile has given you the much needed
break on your wireless bill mint mobile
lets you order from home and save a ton
of money with phone planes starting at
just 15 bucks a month yeah gang order
day at mintmobile.com garbage one more
time that's mintmobile.com let's get to
the show
welcome so another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit there with your
favorite comedians and we find it at the
group to be classy aren't they just a
big old piece of trash I'm your host
Dave trolley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
hoodies in the new edition I just saw
her out front she was paying off a
Little League umpire okay yeah been on
the Spartans this year all right my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me I kind of got him this week a
little bit right there's a little bit of
a chuckle there smirk he is the CEO of
are you garbage she is an international
businessman but always the king of the
boardwalk baby give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan what's up gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure
your rate of you subscribe on iTunes
full video of elm old YouTube as you
know those numbers are cooking then
obviously the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang
sign up over there it's a gosh darn
party yes sir and having a nice quick
shout out to our producer X Jordan Air
the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones the twos the threes and
the fours he crosses the t's and he dots
the eyes give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Toby McMullen everybody what
up dudes what up Tebow what up pal man
talk about a guy who comes in with just
like dope Uncle Vibes he's got two
dollar bills for all the kids he's an
all-time hang oh man Uncle Sal at
Christmas I'd be hovering around you are
you kidding me get the door for you sir
that's true actually
gang we could be more excited to have
our incredibly and I mean incredibly
special guest back with us again today
uh we absolutely love them you guys love
him he is on tour right now and this is
all leading up to a brand new special
that he's going to be recording at the
Vic Theater in Chicago Illinois which
goes on pre-sale September 13th and 14th
and goes on full sale September 15th
give it up for salvacano
the pre-sale code is no pressure
thank you very much I appreciate it
congratulations buddy thank you so much
looking at you it's so good to see you
guys thank you in a minute thank you
both I love you guys I gotta say just
say one thing sure out of every single
pie we have you know we're all Comics we
all have podcasts we all are in the same
little like click together out of all
the podcasts I swear there's there's
none that is as well put together
conceptualized and and and and then
conceived and like and done better than
you guys thank you and I really truly
truly from the bottom of my heart mean
that thank you everything is it works
together and it just is amazing you guys
carve this thing out and it's the most
fun podcast to do and it just you know
it's like when you know when a comic is
like a young comedy yeah you gotta find
your voice you gotta find your voice
some this podcast is just just just
pitch perfect
yeah yeah no pressure be funny
you have to break it down all right guys
take care thank you guys
we were gonna hit you up for money now I
guess we can't
uh do you speaking of that do you do you
go around at Christmas and everybody
gets a little something with the younger
kids in the fam I have my birthday is
November 6th so as a kid uh I used to
take all my birthday money save it and
use it on Christmas gifts that's just I
kind of like I just I love Christmas
yeah and so like I bought weed
I continue that tradition so I'm the guy
no joke when you said that I'm like you
don't even know because I like have a
note in my um in my phone a note page
that's like potential Christmas gifts so
I'm always adding to it so if I see or
think or see something someone likes
like six months earlier nine months ago
or I see something I think I make a
running list and then I because I
literally take it to Christmas people
are always just like and my family you
know and extend the family and friends
they're just like I can't wait to open
this because I know you've been putting
some thought into this ah dude that's
awesome we had a we have an Uncle Frank
in our family and when he would show you
20 bucks he would show up on Christmas
Day he'd always have an envelope for all
the kids
I love that scene it was like he was at
a nail salon we'd be all over him yeah
that's always whether you you clocked
them when they come in and if you see
the envelope yeah
something yeah my dad's grandma Grandma
Rose she did this thing I don't know why
she did it but it was great and we just
always like that's the way it was when
you were leaving like it's like a lot of
grandmas do it but she like really like
every time she'd be like on the way out
she'd hit me with a five I'd be like
don't tell nobody yeah now I don't know
why she was so scared of that
information getting back yeah they're
always real like they stolen herself
five bucks and she used to say don't
don't say nothing if the cops ask you
you found that yeah you want it shooting
dice
don't do anybody is all right see me on
the street you call me Larry
but yeah there was something Eve that
made it even more cooler yeah you know
what I mean I was like I won't say
anything yeah dude I I had I had an aunt
who's still like up until maybe two or
two or three years ago would still hit
me with like 30 or 40 at Christmas and
like I'm doing because I needed it so
long right I'm like I'm doing fine it's
okay she didn't believe you no nobody
did nobody did yeah you almost still
want to accept it because it's like a
thing you know what if you're bad but
I'm also like I'm Bolding like I don't
need your money
if I need this 30
yeah exactly 30's not getting me out of
the out of the red you know your
checkbook on you baby I'm jammed up you
ever see that sign felt up sure she's
sending checks he never cashes them yes
yes
and crap but then he goes and catches
them all she's so patrolled yeah and she
goes down to the bank first thing in the
morning yeah all you want to do is make
two lefts go down yeah it's great I
didn't know you were a big sign guy all
right oh yeah oh yeah
yeah I used to I used to come home I was
way into it I mean I catch it like the
first run in like 90 when it got
canceled and brought back it ever came
back I was on board big and I used to I
used to deliver pizza and my shift
within would end at 11 but if there was
no customers you could mop and and get
ready so that like at 10 50 sometimes my
boss would be like get out of here I
live five minutes away so literally
speed home and because I didn't know how
to work the timer on the VCR oh that was
what I used to yeah taped signed the
Seinfeld upset 11 on VHS I have a marble
notebook to this day where I would write
the episode and write the uh the three
or four plot points on it the log and
then I would you know log and I had all
the video cassettes before it came out
like on video and stuff yeah it is a it
is an education on how to write I mean
that's why you're that's why you have a
very successful TV show it's that stuff
you look back and you're like oh yeah
like you were you were breaking down the
plots of Seinfeld yeah absolutely I
actually
um met Jerry in 19 January 1995. I was
18.
[Laughter]
schedule money
I went on my first ever plane ride with
two friends to California I'd never been
on a plane before and we went to crash
up my my friend's older cousin was in a
rock band called sister whiskey nice
that's a pretty good name that's a
pretty good Bad Day right and they were
like it was back when like there was
like still that like good old time like
rock and roll like a poison type of
thing sure and they they signed a deal
with Warner Brothers and they had a one
single that came out and it was like wow
we gotta go so we went there we crashed
on this couch for two weeks it was my
first time you probably felt famous
you're crashing on the couch a whiskey
sisters bass player yeah it was well he
had a rabbit that everywhere and he
didn't even pick it up so I didn't feel
too famous
it was I I like man these guys are
really rock and roll there was two
couches and then on the floor there's
three of us so like I I I there's
definitely days I was on amongst the
rabbit yikes but it was a it was a
blast nonetheless what was young Sal's
style back then were you were you living
the Motley Crew lifestyle it was grunge
at that time okay I had hair down onto
here really oh yeah yeah man I got I
could show you some pics you know if you
want to stay a little late after class
check out my office but we went out
there and just by chance uh one night we
went to Jerry's Famous Deli no relation
no there really is no relationship it's
a restaurant out there it's like three
or four of them okay so we're in there
we're just eating and that's closer to
their closing time and when we walked in
there was two sheet cakes right at the
front in like the foyer area it said
nothing fancy this place is like a
glorified Diner yeah it said
congratulations Seinfeld on your 100th
episode so we sat down the waiter comes
over I'm like what is this and he goes
oh yeah they'll be here tonight and I go
what they'll be in this place he goes
they actually come every single week
right after the taping oh it's a
tradition and they've been doing it for
years and they have a meal together here
so they rented out the place when we
close and the whole cast crew
everything's coming here to celebrate it
damn I said you're kidding I mean at the
time he was my idol already I remember
that 100th episode you think that's
where they went afterwards right right
and I go okay so is there any way we can
stay he says I can't do that so we
dressed up like a busboy
[Laughter]
my pizza
we took as long as we possibly could you
know and like and then we paid the check
we were like close to last and they
closed it we went outside and we were
like oh we want something to sign in
case we meet him so he ran to a
bookstore I bought sign language wow
nice we came back and it started to pour
now one of my other friends was as big a
fan as me and my friend whose cousin was
the rock guy he wasn't so actually shout
out Dom de bartholomeo he's now a big
guy in L.A he owns this uh this Beverly
Hills wine and cheese shop and he he
makes and literally he got famous off of
making uh Italian uh delicacy food from
ola's grandmother's recipes
it's called domenicos and he makes the
it's like he started with just sun-dried
tomatoes and now he has a whole lot
career remember when those hit sun-dried
tomatoes it was like metallic yeah that
was big monsters that was big they're
not as big no no I love them yeah yeah
not everywhere yeah they're not but long
story short
uh they sat across the street uh in a
car because they didn't care and it
started to because it started to pour
and we just waited out there in the
pouring rain and the people started to
come start to come start to come and
we're like waiting to see him and then
all of a sudden we see our friends
flashing the from across the street and
people thought it was a hit just great
they're like and so we run over like
what happened he just pulled up in his
Porsche the Porsche right in front of
you got out and walked in and you didn't
see him you just missed him he walked in
right past us the Porsches right there
like we didn't see him so we're like oh
my God now we gotta wait so you waited
till he came out I waited till he came
so we were like we're gonna wait here
he's in it so it was all windows so we
saw them I'm like oh my God this this
you know this Jason Alexander I don't
think we saw uh Kramer but
um Michael Richards but so we just
waited but by chance he came out to
smoke a cigar alone whoa and he came out
and we were like oh my God he's standing
right there and he's talking to the
valet only the two people standing
outside so he walk up to him we say
excuse me Jerry huge huge fans
um we were waiting for you we you on the
way in he goes yeah I saw you standing
here when I walked in I thought you were
gonna say hello yeah I was like would
you mind signing this no he signed sign
language and then we go would you mind
taking a photo okay film camera and he
goes yeah you know and he was really
cool about it he took a photo
I still have it I I put it up online so
if you Google me and him he's probably
out there I was 18. and um he took the
photo and then we were like thank you so
much and then we walked across the
street to our friends and it was still
kind of raining and we were just like in
shock a little bit and we were like we
have to is that was that the end like
should we we were those guys sure so
he's still standing out there right so
like like he never circled back never I
mean ever the job's done you got the
money run I was so young I mishandled
this and uh let me get kills back up to
so what what happened was he he irished
so he threw the cigar out and he went to
go get in his car and we're like oh my
God he's leaving I'm like we don't know
what to do and so we were in the we were
we were selling to walk back and it's
raining and we just we just yelled Jerry
Jerry and he's like yeah that's me was
there really a second spitter right from
the good line right
so hot like he hasn't heard that
before so he goes like he was like all
right and then he went to get in his car
and it was raining we didn't know what
to do and my friend just keeps walking
toward him and as Jerry's trying to
start the car he just takes a picture of
him in his own car from the he just
walks up to the he has a picture of
Jerry Seinfeld like this in his Porsche
like with all raindrops on the window
like trying to start its car and then
you just like sped out and win yeah
there it is yeah is that you that is my
friend was on the other side I cut him
out because I didn't know if he wanted
to be in this place but uh yeah
look at that Jan
95.95 yeah we followed him home never
met him it's me from Jerry's never
bumped into him again Santa he's he's
bumped me a couple times uh not not me
but like I was next and he's coming the
lineup sure yeah and uh yeah but I've
never really talked to him again I was
scared to talk to you when I first met
you no I didn't what are you talking
about
but people ask me that like I remember
when you follow you followed ayg's
Instagram page or something for real
yeah and I was like I remember I texted
I think we did a three-way call I was in
the car like Sal just following us I
swear to God really yeah that's that's
so flattering you started writing checks
we're in boys
just make sure we're around them during
Christmas but people like people at home
or something like that if I'm like oh
yeah it was as stellar and you know
so-and-so came in I was like oh what'd
you say to him what do I say to him I
shouldn't say anything about
walking up hey what's going on good to
see you especially Jerry when he would
like walk into Gotham yeah that's where
he bought me twice the jeans the nice
Blazer and like a cool like rich guy
baseball yeah like a Net Jets hat or
something like that that's how he came
in with a Blazer as a matter of fact I
was up next and I had a spot like an
hour later so I was like whatever right
so he came in I was like all right I I
almost didn't go that night I almost
like for some reason I have to cancel
I'm like oh thank God I came yeah I got
to watch him so he goes up there for
about 30 minutes and then he's about to
get off I'm like oh my God I have to
follow him which actually I don't really
mind like it depends the situation it's
a little it's sometimes if they're big
enough there's a built-in kind of like
you know I mean I'm still I had a decent
enough set I don't think I was gonna
bomb but also like you kind of want that
experience you want to see how it goes
what if it goes good what if it doesn't
either way you have a story you follow
Seinfeld and if you bomb you go well I
bombed I was following something right
it doesn't matter I'm thinking like all
right am I switching am I sit around
what am I going to do you know he says
he's going I'm like when he's gonna stop
25 minutes 30 minutes you know 35 then
he goes thank you guys you know everyone
cheers I'm like oh here we go because
and then he goes you know
a lot of people ask me who I think is
funny
he goes and I want to bring someone up
next who I actually think is is funny
ladies and gentlemen and he goes like
this and I'm just like did Club do you
think it's you I I don't know I don't
but I but it's I'm real timing this is
really it could be that Showbiz thing
like maybe he's just bringing me up he's
doing the night I don't think he
remembers me from Jerry's dad
this guy when I met him he creeped me
out for an hour I think it was Jan 95.
it was raining that night I had the
pastrami on Ryan and a pickle so I'm
just I I didn't know like I'm literally
it's just while I'm just processing as
he's saying these words and I'm like
maybe the club told them I was supposed
to be next and not sure and maybe he's
just being kind because he has no idea
who I am but how long ago was this this
was um
you're famous pre-pandemic I was already
on the show okay yes but um and then for
The Listener at Gotham you're not coming
from backstage you're in the room right
by the stage you're walking to the left
of the stage and I'm just like I can't
believe this is about to happen
I don't know maybe they told him I
didn't know he knew the show and he's
being nice to me of course you picture
you two in a convertible just driving
yeah
you know the amount of things I thought
in those 10 seconds oh dude yes so I
even said maybe he's just being kind to
the unknown comic he you know whatever
and he goes a lot but he said it so
sincerely and the crowd was just like
looking like who does Jerry think is
funny and I was standing like 10 feet to
the right estate just like and he goes
ladies and gentlemen Dave Dave Chappelle
and Dave Chappelle moves me out just
goes and then walks past me and goes on
I don't know why man I was like you are
kidding me so now Dave Chappelle is up
there and I'm like all right I get to
watch James chappellen follow Dave
Chappelle actually I probably had a spot
like 90 minutes later because Dave
Chappelle did a literally I I had to
leave for my spot sure yeah and it was
like 45 minutes into Chappelle's yeah so
Jerry did like 25 30 then Chappelle did
like 40 45. and the whole time like my
my every I'm like I'm not gonna follow
either one of them yeah like I'm not
even gonna I have to leave I would have
faked a stomach
pull the fire alarm yeah and I just said
to Andrew whoever was there uh I just
was like I don't know I have no spot out
to go and I left and I didn't get to you
know follow either of them but there was
a you know I never really I don't think
if I ever told that story but when he
was like ladies and gentlemen and I was
right Dave Chappelle and Dave Chappelle
Walks from behind me I didn't know he
was dead I had no idea he was there and
he just and I just like if you could be
in my head at that moment it was like oh
yeah no I know that feeling dude that's
awesome dude who was like you guys ever
have that issue where you had to follow
someone and it's like Jesus Christ I
just had to do I just had to follow
Rogan at the mothership uh knowingly
same thing I was walking up and dropped
in the guy was bringing me up okay and I
didn't know he was there and going up
and he was like this next guy dude I did
the math he's like this next guy a kid
who I just met he's like it's one of my
brothers in comedy and I'm like is he
doing that super nice thing I just met
him and he's I know podcasts
I was in the back of the room I knew he
was dead in the water
I started putting on my coat I don't
like walking I'm you know from me to the
you know the camera to the stage and I'm
like all right and then he's like ladies
and gentlemen
and then Joe brought me up which I would
know we weren't sure was gonna happen so
he's like the next guy coming to the
stage and I'm like I was waiting for it
but you know him right he knows I had
met him for like a minute before I know
him better now we were running the
scenario this is inside baseball we were
running the scenario so Joe Rogan just
went up it's past the mic so the three
scenarios are one he knows Kevin's name
and is going to bring him up that's
great which is we were thinking it's
like a two percent chance yes it still
has a tough road ahead because the place
is going to go nuts and half the people
are going to follow him out to try to
get a picture or whatever two
he's not going to remember him he's just
going to get off stage and they're just
going to go over the god might go now
they weren't sure they were like we
don't know if he knows who's next right
we'll get you I might have to run up
after him or we'll make it over the got
we don't know but we'll get you on stage
I go all right well I'm in the wings
just waiting whatever happens I'll I'll
handle and then he brought me up which
then I started I'm like how the
what you remember my name he's like from
the ru garbage vodka I'm like what the
so then I'm like professional I'm
like processing that while I'm like
shaking his hand on stage
for about three minutes
Kip this is DraftKings baby shout out to
the kings of the draft the NFL is back
let's go gang DraftKings and official
sports betting partner of the NFL is
giving you a can't miss offer for week
one new customers get ready for this you
can get 200 in bonus bets instantly when
you bet just five bucks on any NFL game
damn all customers can snag two new
offers every single game day this
September so download the app and see
what you get yeah download now and use
code ayg to sign up let them know to get
sent you new customers can take home 200
bucks and bonus bets instantly for just
betting five bucks that's code ayg only
on DraftKings Sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the NFL the
crown is yours baby become the king uh
if you got a gambling problem call 1-800
Gambler visit
www.1800gambler.net in New York you can
call 8778 Hope and why or text Hope and
why in Connecticut help is available
forget for for problems with gambling
call
888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsible on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resorts
21 plus age varies by ju by jurisdiction
void in Ohio
cdkng.co football for eligibility terms
and responsible gaming resources bonus
bets expire seven days after issuance
eligibility and deposit restrictions
apply doing okay let's talk about ladder
shout out the latter gang we need the
breadwinner to the family you don't want
to leave them holding the bag if
something unforeseen should happen you
know what I'm talking about take it just
take a dirt nap screwing everybody when
you're six feet under but with ladder
you can take care of the ones that take
care of you and the ones that you love
ladder is 100 digital no doctors no
needles no paperwork when you apply for
three Milli in coverage that's three
Bells baby just answer a few questions
about your health and you'll be on your
way uh ladder smart algorithms work in
real time so you find out if you're
instantly uh if you're approved uh with
A and A Plus ratings and am best and a
4.8 out of 5 stars on trustpilot you can
go ahead and blindly follow that YouTube
tutorial with that peace of mind if you
die at least your family won't be
destitute man they got you hey they're
calling balls and Strikes over here on
ladder so go to ladderlife.com garbage
today to see if you're instantly
approved takes it don't take that long
you ain't got to sit down with a guy
with bad coffee breath that's ladder
life
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com garbage
matterlife.com garbage do it gangnam
back to the show back to the show one
time at an open mic wolf Larson
funniest guy in Chicago
he's dead now but shout out to Wolf
I had to follow Louis at the store
but it was I think it was scheduled so I
knew I was doing that but that was also
like oh you know but but it's fine yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's one of those
things you've you have to you're like
this sucks in the moment or
whatever like as you're leading up to
your mind's racing but then it's one of
those things of like you get off you're
like oh I can do that I'm glad I did
that and you feel you feel way better
after yeah oh man that's great that was
fun all right yeah that was awesome
it's all started to Jerry's Deli
that's what I'm talking about
um all right but let's we gotta we got
to get into some of it it's always good
time hanging with Sally V over here
um the show is up yeah it's been a while
since you've been here so there's been
some hot button issues or some things up
for debate uh that we don't really have
the answer on that if we originally
disagreed on and then we opened it up to
everybody want to get your take on some
of these things
um let's let's do this you're getting
dressed right you get out of the shower
sure uh you put your underwear on then
you do you put your socks and then pants
or pants and then socks
okay I'll say as a general rule I
probably so here's the thing I knew he
was going to happen he was going to have
a take on this because I do both and it
depends on the pant I'm putting on
because sometimes if the pan has a
little bit of a tapered ankle it's a
little bit it takes a little bit more
elbow grease to get the shot the way you
wanted to pull it down over it and I
don't have that kind of time so busy man
if it's a tight pant i i i consciously
put the sock on first okay but in in
general I would say I actually put the
pants on first that's the way I roll
what if you were putting on a suit
the socks are going on first yeah
because you can't mess with because
you're going to wrinkle it needs to be
no extra Fanfare right after the pants
are on sure and I and I also will have
the uh jacket I won't put it on until I
arrive at the event I'll lay down
if you're driving with the sport coat on
to the wedding you're gonna look like an
idiot are you how do you how do you feel
in a suit are you confident in a suit or
they like I know with us we're you know
me and him are bigger guys so it's like
I feel like sure communion immediately
yeah
yeah it's just you put it on the fuse is
lit and you're I'm gonna look bad in an
hour it depends on a stage in my life
but when I am which is most of the time
when I feel like you know I'm definitely
like too too heavy it just feels like
I'm like just putting like makeup on a
donkey yeah
I'm just looking like I just look like I
am like I'm a guy in like a large amount
of textiles yeah that is trying to look
fancy like it just feels like okay the
actual material is is elevated sure but
it's just a lot of just it feels like at
the end of the day it's draped over yeah
I mean yeah I go back to being a little
fat kid at a wedding with too much cake
in me and sugar running through my veins
and just my shirt just all over the
place I'm always I'm always playing the
game of should I lift the belt above my
stomach hump oh I always go on so it
looks flat because it's gonna fall under
sure so I start there do I walk in with
it just like at the belly button area so
it looks like I have a flat stomach but
then as soon as I like as soon as like
uh Macarena that thing's dipping down
below the gut go easy on the limbo you
know what I mean I crossed that
threshold last summer I started going
over the gut yeah because the t-shirts
weren't weren't long enough and the
belly would just peek out a little bit
Yeah so I started going over I actually
ended up getting a i this was I found on
Tommy John's website they have these
like undershirts that yes the squeezers
like the one that's like you know it's
like air thin or whatever like that and
then it goes really long it goes down to
like the thigh so that you will never
have it come out and ride up on you oh
you know get eyes on it yeah yeah yeah
yeah and so it's great because a lot of
times if I do a standard undershirt
because you gotta do it on the shirt I
thought you're gonna say it was like
wait you're doing undershirt I don't do
an undershirt when you have a suit shirt
on no no if I do I feel like you can see
if you take the jacket off you see the
you do but I think it's I think it's
acceptable as long as it's you know you
want to hear a pro dirt bag move please
you cut the sleeves
you cut the sleeves off a regular v-neck
make sure it's V so you don't see it
because yeah the double up these and
then you cut the sleeves but wouldn't
you just go with like a a like a guinea
tea you could yeah I don't do guinea tea
either do I I don't they're I don't love
it
yeah yeah but like I the reason I don't
you get nip through there you get sweat
through there uh I don't like it if it
comes up and you or if you move a
certain way and the button like buckles
which is a problem for a bigger guy yeah
yeah the buckling so but what happens is
with the shirt it's a double-edged short
because with the shirt you're a little
hotter yeah and then also you got an
extra you know an extra layer for the
belt yeah so now you're really because
if you think about if you fold a t-shirt
up you see it's still you're in you're
still probably in two or three inches
two inches of circumference yeah take
that thing if you fold a piece of paper
18 times in a row it touches the moon or
whatever right right and so that's that
way too so this is you'd ask a question
I deal with a lot yeah no of course it
does help you with sweat absorption now
when you got it it does and let me tell
you what I do recently they lay it on me
baby
rash guard I abandoned my suits and I
rent for each occasion whoa renting is
easy now it's online it's affordable
it's they make it very very convenient
and then I and it's because depending on
it's now I'm fluctuating because I'm
trying to lose weight for the a special
and so I got another 30 to go but I lost
about 30 and so like you know I never
know when I'm in limbo I have a wedding
October 7th I don't know what I'm gonna
be what wait I'm gonna be at sure so I
wait till about a couple weeks before
and I just I just order it I have an
account I just click it nice yeah are
you still going shirt and tie too or
have you started to cross over into like
light sweater underneath or anything a
ball off shirt and tie your office off
it for weddings or in general when suit
wear every suit wear that's the only
place he's wearing a suit yeah
at a wedding I'm gonna wear the tie but
anywhere else not only have I gotten
you've earned no tie yes of course well
I feel like not only do I do no tie at
non-weddings but I started doing no suit
when it calls for it I started
subscribing to like the Adam Sandler
model where I'm like I'm a comedian you
don't expect much from me I'm the silly
guy here I'm the clown basketball shorts
and a winter jacket shooting three
pointers I don't go like billionaire
status sure with the with the shorts but
I'll show up at like a like a function
that that people are dressed up at like
as long as I got a cool t-shirt on and
then a nice pair of sneakers I'm the
comedian
is this a personal Affair or like work
Affair like something for the show
something for the show you can wear
whatever the like hey I'm the guy
on the thing if it's not a wake or a
wedding I will not put a suit on
anything you just go what jeans and a t
even if it's like oh you got to be
business casual no no no
dude
mock turtleneck chain out well I did
that so I am from Staten Island I mean
you know if you want to if you want to
guys get into 87 to 90 we can talk about
it uh I did did you ever Rock a Dickie
uh
Dicky meaning the fake the half yeah it
just looks like it yeah yeah I had two
when I was little but my mom bought
those I was extra young but when I was
in sixth seven eighth grade uh the style
was this
cavaricis sure usually have a z cat
version Z Cavalry cheese usually have a
belt with like a some ornate like Silver
Buckle in the front uh they would be
tapered they look like empty Hammer
pants that's all free my time but yeah
yeah and then what I'll make you feel
bad about it and uh and I remembered
himself eighth grade dance they were
eighth grade dance and used to wear
white socks with black leather slip-on
loafers that's a look that had a buckle
and then I do a turtleneck cardigan
chain outside the turtleneck yeah you
know I would do mock turtleneck black
mock turtleneck chain on the outside and
a Raiders hat oh yeah
what the hell Rob Base was pumping oh
yeah I got it I got oh sorry no I mean
that was Rob Base was it yeah it was all
right it was all right I got something
because now we we just had a younger
Comic-Con little sash shout out to
little sass shout out to him um
the what if you're wearing ankle socks
right you got a pair of khaki are you a
short Sky now shorts guy got a pair of
khaki shorts on whatever I got all the
shorts
I got all whatever you need and I pushed
through to me to keep being a short Sky
because my legs are 110 bold oh all mine
100 with tight pants I think I mean well
my dad has bald legs so I was
anticipated yes yeah and he doesn't wear
shorts because he hates them and so when
but I see him in short sometimes and
they're literally like glow sticks and
uh so I I was like I won't let that
happen to me I'll tan the Bold like you
know I'll still wear them but yeah yeah
but it got worse and worse and now
there's nothing
um so I do push through that and I get
asked a lot do you swim and I say I swim
but that's not why my legs and I and I
go oh you know I was talking about your
legs I said I know you thought yeah yeah
I saw you looking at them
um what uh what kind of ankle saw what
color ankle sock are you doing are you
doing white or black okay so if I'm
wearing shorts yeah I'm this is an age
I'm going no show on a sock proper
no-show proper no show okay if not it's
black will you ever go no socks and
sneakers
I do it depending on the shoe I'll do it
with my slip-on checkered Vans cool or a
pair that is very comfortable and I
don't mind if it's going to get jacked
up a little stinky yeah but other than
that I'm I'm all over that because I'm a
sneaker guy as well so I have I got him
I got the like the like the inserts in
there to keep them nice I got this the
pine stuff in there you know so I
usually wear a sneaker there was
something I bought that was like a
permanent sock have you ever seen that
no it's in the sneaker it's his company
I forgot what it's called and basically
it's got like a adhesive on it and it's
like a sock and you put it in the shoe
and you cut it to the shoe and so when
you slip your feet in there's a layer in
between that and with the thing yeah I
bought them I saw him in the store once
I was like this is awesome I bought it
10 years ago I have the package exactly
I never opened it and I've never used it
yeah but they're out there in case you
want it no they're no socks and sneakers
that for the first couple wears it feels
great feels great too you look cool
you're getting blisters you're getting
all calluses you're getting that sweat
that sweat once it once you have it
doesn't go away now let me say one other
thing about the no shows please hit me
there's two types of no shows there's
one just below the ankle right just
below it which if you wear like a
slip-on you kind of still see sure you
can still see a lot of those no-shows
you can still see then there's the like
a true I was never here
it's the one that goes and if you take
off your shoe I swear to God it looks
like a ballet slip yeah no it goes all
the way down to the toes and comes back
up so the top of your foot is has
nothing on it now that's if you really
want to look like you have nothing on
but I've noticed that when I've taken
those off and I'm amongst mixed company
I get mocked roundly because I look like
just a fat uh Arena ballerina yeah yeah
my lady one Italian Swan my lady one
time laughs so hard that she had tears
in her eyes and she you know those like
she got into a fit 10 minutes into it
she almost couldn't for the first three
minutes I didn't know why she was living
because she couldn't she just looked at
me and I just looked like a real like a
just a fat Italian ballerina we were on
vacation in Mexico we were in the hotel
room when I was at the closet changing
and she just thought hysterical laughing
we might have smoked but uh but then she
was and then she told me what it was and
then I mean you know what I was doing
ballet moves all over the room yeah baby
yeah I leaned how is your ballet do you
have you think you got a move or two in
there seen enough okay I've seen enough
that's not a good stuff he walks on his
toes out of here I used to walk on my
toes with shoes on though because of
Michael Jackson I used to practice that
sure nice Capezio you know what Capezio
is no did the shoes used to wear that he
like moonwalked in he wore like not
ankle socks but they were like folded
down a little bit down yeah my foray
into no ankles was remember the girls
trans fats what
the girls would have them remember the
girl that's the and they had a little
ball on the back yeah and you would you
would cut that off yes and wear them yes
I would like to are they still sell
those I'm sure you can get yourself sure
2023 baby yeah yeah
um did you ever have to make back in the
day because ankle socks we talk about
this now obviously Products
Manufacturing availability you can get
anything at any point now right but back
in the day in the 90s or even 80s
whatever the getting your hands on a
pair of ankle socks no not everybody
that's why you did it you had to get
them from your mom so did you did you
ever fake them where like you fold the
you fold it down under the heel I can
take a regular pair of crew socks and
fold them
you know I I don't that was cool but
I'll tell you something I did do I was
going later when I was like a teenager
we were going to a discotheque in the
city sure and uh we were online and uh
they had like you know dress codes or
even they didn't they had the door
person being picky and telling you what
you couldn't couldn't do and we were
online and I had a shoe that had some
like it wasn't a it wasn't a dress shoe
like it was just like I don't know if it
was a sneaker but it just wasn't a black
leather shoe or whatever and I saw them
pulling people out of line and not
letting them get in we ran to uh was it
Dwayne Reed or whatever I bought
electric tape and I literally taped my
shoes all of them up down side like I
wrapped them in electric tape so that
online in the dark outside you just you
glance your eyes not going there and I
got in and my shoes were electrical tape
the whole night and that's how the duct
tape shoe Trend hit me all right that
was you yeah I heard stories about it
that's where it got the name the
Electric Slide
wait till he breaks out his moves baby
well one time I was at a club you just
reminded me this I was I went for like
two years to clubs right and I'm at a
club and it was like uh it was it was
one of the ones like when I when ecstasy
came out and like it was more like less
lounge and more like a warehouse where
people were just like walking around
like with the rain like baby pacifiers
yeah and I wasn't that but I I was there
and uh me and my friends are there and
then all of a sudden the dance were like
someone's like back out back out and
they made like a big circle right and it
opened up in the middle of like a night
like it was like like a limelight type
of play it was called Twilight no twilo
or something like that anyway
um everyone backed out and this kid just
a lone kid he just walks in right he has
a backpack on and he he he he he sets
the background he unzips he pulls out a
helmet he puts the helmet on he straps
it in next he goes right down on his
head spins and he just starts spinning
on his head up on the helmet and the
place was cheering they cleared out for
this guy like he does it like they knew
it it's like hey
and then as he's as he's rotating me and
my friends go holy is that I don't
know if I should say his name but it was
some kid from a high school from like
seven years ago Gary yeah well like is
that is that sure yeah Gary and it was
him it was him man he had red hair and
freckles he was like unmistakable and
that was not him in high school him in
high school was it's butterfly under the
raid on nothing and he cleared out a
crowd of this club and put on a helmet
that's awesome yeah and then no one knew
he I mean I don't know if he had that
skill set or developed it later but the
guy spun on his head for like a good 40
seconds
wild ah enough about me and my club days
guys I love that did you ever uh since
we're about the same age did you ever
make the purchase of the of the Michael
Jackson jacket
uh no I had what I passed off as it it
was a fair enough it was a members only
sure
but I had the capezios and I had the
glove you did yeah and I actually have a
Polaroid in for my aunt's house with me
and all of them like being you know like
doing the fight would you wear the glove
like in regular life or would this be a
performance at like Thanksgiving love
was on all the time really you never
know when there's gonna be a duel man
yeah
he was I mean
dude it's hard to explain to people yeah
but it wasn't like the glove the real
glove who do you have to explain Michael
Jackson to when no aliens
you guys weren't even they know about it
they know about it no I know but but how
hard it hit in the early 80s when
Thriller came out it was like I mean I
like the Taylor Swift who yeah sure you
know what I mean people would melt in
front of him yeah it was like the
Beatles sure
um wait who are they
but mine was Jank like I got it I
remember because I got an album like a
promotional album but it was the Jackson
5 album okay so the glove
it wasn't like the one you can get now
it wasn't even like the one he wore I
remember he made them they made him
bring them back and do it yeah after
yeah the picture of my glove is a white
winter it was marketed as Michael
Jackson it was a white winter glove it
was like a sales out there with an oven
it was a wool glove and I still have it
to this day and on it was printed the
Jackson 5 in gold all over the place so
it was it it was his glove
on it but it was like this big I looked
like a Mickey Mouse hand and I and I
wore it everywhere everywhere couldn't
pick nothing up but it was there yeah
look cool uh bam in the uh in the same
vein of putting the socks on first uh
now I assume the shower is a glass door
right like a like a big glass door yeah
that you just step into but back in the
day when it was or let's just say you're
at a hotel that with like a standard
bath with the tub yeah and the thing
and the curtain yeah turn the water on
are you getting in the back of the
shower are you going in front I'm going
in the back okay yeah enter the water
stream yeah yes okay yeah we've
established on the podcast that that is
the gentleman this lunatic gets in the
front yeah well I mean it's still going
it's a wild ride yeah I get what you're
doing you're living on the edge I live
on the edge yeah wake up choosing
violence baby as a matter of fact I do
another thing I turn the hose of the the
head against the top wall so it hits the
top so really no one's getting hurt I
respect and I just kind of like you know
I run my hand to that yeah I'm gonna
regret this and I swore that I wouldn't
bring it up again but since Sal's here
I'm gonna bring it up can I try to set
it up okay because because it's it's I
feel like there's been a lot of
jockeying in the setup of this no he's
lied every time he's brought it up and I
finally got one chance to get it out
straight I'm so excited right now if
you're at a dinner yeah is it uncouth to
order a pizza as an uh as an entree for
yourself
well again I don't want to be stickler
but it depends on the scenario thank you
what is the scenario a little more yeah
you enter a place an Italian restaurant
right that has like the the Coal Fire
Pizza Oven it's on display for everybody
to see they have a handful of specialty
pizzas what are you shaking your head at
I just I shouldn't have brought it up I
know
it's out we needed a hard no out of
the gate man oh I see I see okay all
right all right yeah they're trying to
rewrite history here and I'm not
going to allow it I'm too empathetic for
that guys I always want to be like well
tell me the scenario and we'll walk
through it gently and uh we'll come out
and we'll no no feelings over here what
time of day was it what
didn't you think that even though it is
a Coal Fired Pizza Place an Italian
restaurant they have cold party if
you're gonna do the pizzas wouldn't you
get that to start to share with
everybody and then everybody get normal
entrees they're saying everybody it was
me it was me and my wife it was like 19
people yeah so give me the exact example
and I promise I'll shoot straight thank
you that's why we invited you I wasn't
even gonna bring it up I swear to God
damn it he's from Staten Island what are
you doing he's on Pro Pizza side
but he's probably got some getting
delivered here in a couple minutes
for Christmas I delivered them for five
years yeah yeah
um okay so me and my wife we go this has
been tread on a bunch me and my wife we
go out it's one of the uh it's not it's
not in the city it's in the suburbs they
have like a big Coal Fire Pizza thing
people are ordering pizzas it's on the
menu there's probably about four or five
specialty pizzas they do
we get an app we split an app she gets
uh like the carbonara or something like
a pasta dish I get the pizza at the
whatever Pizza I forget what it was uh
you know the Margarita Pizza sure uh she
has a slice of the pizza I have a bite
of the carbonara is that crazy
absolutely not thank you in that
situation I wouldn't even blink these
two people I can't believe it's the
topic of contention they act like I
slapped a waiter in that scenario you
know if you're at a you know a little
bit of a fancy place or you're with a
whole bunch of like a whole big table I
I don't know I still think if if that's
one of their showcase items uh yeah
showcase items is what we're using from
here on out
you know you know that's something
they're known for and I'll see if it's a
place that serves pizza it is a little
bit relaxed already yeah I don't know if
there's an etiquette necessarily now if
you order a pizza like one of these
pizzas like this I didn't get it
delivered and there's eight people at
the table and you order a pizza and
everyone else is Andre I'd feel a little
I load a lot yeah well okay all right I
concede and the woman on the phone when
I called her what are you doing it got
done and we called on air we called the
restaurant I'm not the judges or did you
really yeah
I gotta be honest with you on the call I
thought I was dead in the wall I was
really trying well these two were
screaming at me call me a piece of
for an hour wow yeah I figured out why I
was so opposed to it too it's because
when I was a little kid we went to like
a TGI Fridays or something and I or I
went to order the pizza my mom was like
you don't get pizza at a restaurant oh
Freddy's I mean yeah okay she's like
this is TGI Fridays yeah not Mondays not
Tuesdays not Wednesdays order a
entree
[Laughter]
pizza boy
oh man since we're all on the thing of
pizza are you uh obviously Staten Island
Pizza the whole nine yards sure given
let's say you're on the road somewhere
you're in you know Yuma or
something the only thing that's
available is Domino's or Pizza Hut what
are you leaning towards Pizza Hut really
yeah but Pizza doesn't deliver
and I'm not going there so it's going to
end up dominoes would you would you go
to a Pizza Hut on Staten Island when you
were a kid or was it always a local spot
no uh we there was a pizza now we would
go yeah pizza was kind of something
special you did a salad bar let me do
the salad bar and they had the beautiful
red plastic cups yes they did you know
and they did bring it over in that in
still in the skillet like hot yeah you
know and it looked like it did on TV
that's one thing they did right it did
it looked exactly as advertised yeah
don't get me wrong we did regular pizza
too but that was the sole exception was
pizza the long spatula
you know you're not coming out it's
terrific they even had a really nice uh
they had a uh what they have in the in
the foyer of the one I went to they had
an NFL uh they had a arcade game that I
was just like what's the one like was it
blit no it had it it wasn't Blitz the
one like well like if you're Mike
Singletary you just run down the field
and nobody could stop it that's what it
was it okay yeah yeah they always had
one mine had one I I think it was a guy
Pac-Man or something at the time I
remember you were the original handheld
football game it was you were just a
little down red dot yeah yeah I got that
they remade those now there's a whole
big vintage toy like uh push that thing
once you figure that out man you were
Unstoppable yeah oh yeah one time I went
to uh so I was on the road and I was
just with my my lady and we were going
to a movie and there was we were in the
middle of I don't know where we were it
might as well been Yuma sure and uh we
we were like let's bring a pizza into
this movie we're going with like a
midnight movie it's wild yeah and so it
was a dominoes in the big parking lot of
the movie theater and so we went in I'm
gonna sound like I'm some like I'm
Cheech and Chong but I was high but I
don't get oils you know I was high at
the time and we went into a Domino's and
his two kids working at teens and uh I
go I'll take whatever this regular pizza
pepperoni right and we're waiting in
like in there there's no seating we're
waiting in there and the kid was like
you know they couldn't have been less
interested and as a you know and there
they're not making it from scratch like
he pulled out the thing and maybe you
put the cheese I don't know but I see
him take
I didn't pay attention long enough but I
see him take a pepperoni right and I see
him go like this like he threw it down
almost like a like you know like Emerald
Legacy he just he made a thing of it
like he threw it down like I heard it
like slap the the thing and I I didn't
think anything else you know he's a
Showboat or something this guy's showing
off hot shot didn't for a
promotion right exactly and then I
didn't look again got the pizza we drove
to the thing
um maybe we ate it in the car right
before the place that's what we did
because I opened it in the car and when
I opened it it was the only pepperoni it
was dead center and it was the only
pepperoni that's a you I know I was
like we we lost our because think
about that I was trying to process it
like was he high was he was he like
you like was he angry did he know I
don't know who why how who that doesn't
work it's a sausage town I'm not gonna
come back we laughed so hard but then I
was like this son of a I don't
know whether it'll be like good one or
like go back there one pepperoni did you
end up bringing the pizza into the into
them I think we just ate it I think
we went in with whatever else we bought
in because I was gonna ask for his
pizzas and entree testimony to be
stricken from the record what if he took
a pizza if he took a Domino's Pizza
which I would allow because that's in
bonco I'll tell you to this day though
well man not not too much today but I I
am still I can still do it and I did it
my whole life I brought food in I I feel
food or snacks food and snacks what are
we talking about we started snacks and
food that my mom started that we
snuggled I smuggle that into Yankee
Stadium she well they let you like you
know but she used to bring like you know
you're bringing like a lunch oh she's
tin foil right but uh I used to bring
whatever I wanted in there you know
snacks but I also wasn't above bringing
in a hero I would go to like you know
this Deli and bring it in right in my
pocket
but then I know I I then I was I was a
cold hero the cold here nothing too
smelly no no not like a tuner no but
I'll going Subway before going in there
but then you gotta really unwrap it's
like you gotta wait for an action
sequence you know what I mean and
especially with like the Sun Chips you
really gotta wait it out oh man somebody
blow something up I'm starving
do that because it's like you know
you're not getting into a bag of Sun
Chips without getting busted cold yeah I
had to go see like something like made a
glass yeah
it's like breaking a window man the Sal
really loves The Expendables
watching the piano
wedding looking at yourself
literally mom man who chose Terms of
Endearment
[Laughter]
is he gonna step on that plastic bag
um yeah but then I learned that like
they really make most of their uh ever
since the pandemic I won't do it because
I know that's where they make a lot of
money but as a kid when they want to
charge me seven dollars for a raisinette
to me that's always I never did we never
did it uh snuck stuff in that I was
always part of the experience yeah I was
such a what are you gonna get what are
you those cameras were better than the
ones yeah like 7-Eleven the boxes were
bigger okay I would still get popcorn or
nachos but I would I would you were a
Nachos
actually I don't really love popcorn to
tell you the truth but yeah but I would
get nachos but I would still sneak in my
own water sure and my own candy yeah I
loved it I loved getting it there the
waiting what do you get you're in the
car big box the big big thing
you can get snow caps in the cities no
caps yeah but let me tell you something
right now go ahead contents settled
during delivery in those boxes because
you pop open that snow cat box and it
was 30 yeah sure and I used to it was a
light dusting a little Hoodwinked each
time as well sure yeah so that kind of
fueled my sneaking yeah uh all right
let's see here uh uh I guess we got one
more from the from these staples you're
putting on deodorant right in the
morning you already got your you went
pants socks whatever are you doing
deodorant before the shirt or after the
shirt 100 of the time after the shaft of
the shirt because I can't risk getting
the that's also another bigger guy move
along the shirt yeah because that stuff
don't come out it just doesn't it's like
toothpaste like that you have to go that
through a proper wash you can't go like
yeah just later on it comes right back
and so but I do very very carefully I
like hold it and I literally make sure I
don't get it uh but you put the shirt on
after or no you put the deodorant on
after no if well I put I put the I put
the shirt on 100 of the time first first
if there's ever a situation where not it
has to be like a surgeon yeah and that's
why I do it because every time I every
single time I mess it up and the problem
is if you do you do do that like for me
I've ran into it like five times where
you put the deodorant on then you put
the shirt on you notice the stain as
you're walking out the door you go
I gotta change my shirt but now you're
in the same position with all right
deodorant on and now you're gonna you
know also the flip side is no walk in
the park either no it's stretches it out
yeah because you gotta then I gotta go
like this and I gotta like pull and I
gotta make sure I'm not just applying it
to the shirt because the deodorant I use
is a soft solid and it comes up like you
know and it's something I do Secret I'll
meet you I do a dog I was secret for a
long time no no no the soft sound
they're baby powder base which is way
better oh okay light and fresh did you
rock the gel remembering Gillette had
them and they come back to the great
lights I put that on it would make me
sweat more yeah that's what the soft
solid does but I never f with gels ever
and uh I never I never ever got
um guys deodorant either I hate though I
don't need like a turbo Forest really I
don't need that no spice no I can't yeah
it's all musky and it's like you know
it's always just like you know tropical
like Tropic blast oh it's very
fabricated it's very manufactured it's
not like a natural smell I do this
before that I did degree and degree too
degree for a while was unisex yes yeah
many years and then someone said no it's
that original degree smelt so good it
was like a light blue yes almost
turquoise turquoise
that was my go-to I forgot about it and
let me tell you something right now that
that was some really good deodorant it
was and someone over there props to them
they decided to take that exact
deodorant and make it men and women's
sure and then call it extra strength
because the old stuff already had that
like whatever that thing is in it that's
like no you're not gonna sweat this is
gonna you know sure it was already in it
but then they remarketed it as some type
of extra and they started charging
instead of 3.99 for that same exact
stick they started charging 10.99 damn
yeah believe it
shout out to the poison Market yeah and
then I switched from degree to secret
and that's everything that I can say to
you about my deodorant in the past I do
I do use that I do use the Old Spice
just deodorant no anti-pursement
antiperspirant but what I do too is if I
forgot my Kelowna for traveling I forgot
my cologne or couldn't take it I will do
a little
on the shoulder just in case I get a hug
I use it as cologne outside no on the
inside before I put my shirt on I'll
just do a little crazy to get a little
fragrant going
in case you had a hug they'd be like oh
he smells like because there's a bigger
guy yeah you got to play all the angles
okay and if like you know you're giving
like a you know platonic hug to a girl
right and you get the oh he smells good
right right okay a little less
disgusting right okay yeah that's nice
he smells better than I thought
I will go like I won't just stay in this
area I'll go a little lower if you saw
the amount of view over the road if you
saw the amount of deodorant I put on you
would be
yeah
and antiperspirant yeah I haven't sweat
under my arms in my life cauterized
without a doubt right yeah without a
doubt right now I'm gonna get like
double armpit cancer but like Sal are
you crying no she's hot here how about
your eyes
dude I had my buddy Pat watch me put it
on one time we were like getting ready
he's like I did it he goes what was that
like he was so shocked I go on I'm put
on he's like that's an insane amount of
deodorant for any human to wear yeah
it's it's this it's yeah yeah it's a lot
it's a lot go down to the Elbow unload
of the nipple I don't know if we asked
you but do you dabble in any cologne at
all I don't uh as uh in part of my life
I'd stop like 25 years ago because I get
nauseous okay any perfume any cologne I
get like literally nauseous and when
when like when I'm on a plane and the
woman next to me is like doused in like
that like some type of terrible perfume
I literally like I get like watery eyes
scratchy throat and I want to vomit so I
had to give it up and and the Cavalry
Chi days though what were you using the
car no I didn't do your car back then I
did uh CK one and I also did a little
sweet one
had one
um I had a whole I mean I had 10
colognes then yeah yeah yeah it's
unclear do it by mood there was uh
what's that one the Armani uh what's
that one Giorgio Armani yo it was uh
yeah Light bottle was it like water or
something like that something water
but let me tell you the cologne that
came that ended all the other colognes
and then I was like I don't need any of
this I gave all my clones away and I
only bought the same cologne for this
what year are we talking this uh I wore
this I wore this cologne I know what it
is uh I'll say late
late 90s early 2000s yeah Aqua de Geo no
but that is the one we were trying yeah
water I don't know if you're gonna I
don't know if you're gonna get it but
but it was I'll give you a hint it had a
nice Citrus to it
eternity no bod who
said that
you son of a no curve no Obsession
oh good guys all good guess uh uh lemail
no the body the guy's body how about I
tell you the company maybe not the name
okay it was by Clinique Clinique yes sir
hmm that's girl stuff Clinique it's not
though
it was wonderful and that I wore that
until like the doors fell off and then I
stopped I think it was cold I think it
was called Happy
it must be it's the first result for
Clinique no kidding man you were just a
good guy in your bones even your your
smell is happy
you are the nicest guy in comedy I'm a
very literal guy yeah
wow I was wearing bitter and angry
resentful
I strikeout my dumbass saw this and I
was like there must be some sort of
Pharrell collab they did like the song I
would think that too
happy for men cologne that's it that's
the bottle that's the color it's still
it's still out yeah for sale right now
yeah I might say that's the time I might
pick that up I just got a bottle from
DXL they added it was an Impulse huge
bacon
what's DSL it's a fat guy
I thought you was I thought you saw the
shipping company
like it just arrived at my door I got it
it was delivered by DXL would you want
to smell four days late
uh yeah man all right next time you show
them through Sephora give it a spray I
will I will I can't even go into a
Sephora I can't go into a Yankee Candle
oh I get a migraine headache I just
don't got caught stealing or something
we gotta get to some listener questions
uh we can we can bang out a couple here
um let's see here this is from Mayhem
first time long time ten dollar homie
shout out to you have you ever made a
custom Sports Jersey like with your name
on it yeah yeah really yeah what age we
talking
now yeah I got so many
on the back oh you know what no so okay
given tea is different give it to me
yeah
you're selling out the O2 Arena and they
give you an Arsenal jersey or whatever
so I have those sure yeah okay
yeah I haven't ordered it out of the
back of East Bay yeah I have like 60
jerseys I don't wear them because I'm
not a jerk I don't have the body for a
jersey you know I can't that makes me
look even wider you know what I would
love to do but I feel like it's really
given up with is to the baseball jersey
unbuttoned if I leaned into that a lot
that covers a lot yeah that's what I
want to do I I've been giving giving
those also like as gifts from not like
shows but gifts like I even have
sweatshirts with the number one name on
the back so I have a bunch of those
Chrissy D rocks those but he can pull it
off he's got his body yeah
um uh but uh you know and then also the
ones like when you join the team I got
those but I know you're not talking
about that sure but I did make a custom
one recently a Steelers jersey that said
big ziti on the back that's fun but that
was for fun yeah
big ziti baked ziti okay cool I thought
two words I thought I thought it was big
CD and that's real fun too yeah what's
up I'm Sal aka Big Z oh man check out my
special tape
can we can you be Sal big ziti volcano I
tell you right right you gotta start
loaning money I'll tell you for the
future of this podcast and our lives if
I come on here you do not say my name
and my last name ever again ladies and
gentlemen
yeah Tebow that's a home run my credits
could be the same but you just call me
big ziti big ziti give it up for big
ziti everybody man that's all right okay
man uh this is from Uncle Rico uh ever
worn a t-shirt with an airbrush design
on it yeah that was big enough that was
uh Jersey Shore you know I'm sure we had
those and I actually recently
um had merch designed inspired by that
we were kind of thinking about doing it
I didn't know that we were kind of
thinking about doing the same you
definitely have a couple of old-timey
photos too right like you was like a
cowboy in a Saloon or holding like the
time
I took a picture of one that I had when
I was little and I did another one as an
adult so I have two nice yeah
yeah you thought you were walking into
Hollywood yeah but the kid one I was
afraid I I never forget it they put me
in like a like a top coat and a hat and
a cane and like they had these big
lights and I didn't want to do it I I
was like five sure and then everything
was big on me and they took the picture
and it literally I could find the
picture I don't want to waste time on on
this but I can find and a picture of me
it's black and white and they put it in
that frame that's oval yeah like a brown
paper frame it looks like it's you know
the old time and it's just me like this
your hands off me and I lost it and I
got so sad because I remembered I was
like I've never seen that again and then
like after like 10 years of thinking it
was gone forever I found it in a book
and I got it back and that's why I took
a photo of it because I was like I'll
never lose you again I let you go once
uh all right let's see here this is uh
this one's from Greg have you ever moved
Furniture a few blocks using only a
dolly
that's all right no uh no not moving all
right let's see let's do one more and
then we can wrap it up uh oh this is
this has been another big fashion one
this is from David Nell are you garbage
if you used to just tuck the tuck in the
front of your shirt
you thought you were getting away with
something I loved it that was a style
yeah I did it a lot 92 probably yeah you
blouse out the back you know the front
you keep the back you know out and man
it was like you know you were you know
kind of neat but you were cool yeah a
little bit you know you were a little
bit of an edge to you still yeah I used
to do it with a Tommy Hilfiger shirt
dude I love that couldn't tell you
nothing nope I remember the collar was
too big so we got it like Marshalls or
whatever it was like a misprint man it
was like a mocked it was a bad look and
I'd be on the Wildwood Boardwalk
trolling for chicks
strike it out end up getting my picture
taken an old timey Place dude I I don't
see that anymore no I'm sure cooler you
know who does it who I just I I call it
we were down in Wildwood actually but
Tommy Pope do you know Tommy Pope comic
right yeah he uh he does something
somewhere but he's a very in shape
good well-dressed guy and he he can he
he does that oh the half talk it's
called the French tuck is it really oh
yeah that's when I put my wiener between
my legs
I always thought it was out of necessity
because the my wiener
I don't want no one seeing it you don't
want to you don't want to um you don't
want to tuck but uh but the shirt's too
long the dress sure I will do now I'll
do an abbreviation of that as a bigger
guy you know if it hangs because it's
finding something that fits with and
length is tough for me so I'll tuck the
side in to my belt and it just bunches
up it's a little time you taught me that
and it just hangs it folds up on one
side the other side shortens up a little
bit I do it on stage all the time yeah
maybe throw a bomber jacket over that no
one's another wife
I've done it and I've also done the
front half only and leave one flap
hanging so it's like just like that yeah
so it's like it wasn't even might not
even been attention sure yeah I'm so
casual you I don't even know what's
happening yeah
like I don't know I got things to do I
have been thinking about this for four
days I didn't talk and untuck that half
tuck ten times serious
I didn't take a hand mirror to my
medicine cabinet mirror to see what I
look like from behind for 10 minutes
before I left that's crazy I'm a cool
guy that's called a sheriff's pinch
they're just making this up now get out
of here
ladies and gentlemen Mr Sal vulcano love
you man thank you on tour right now yes
like 25 cities up right now pre-sale for
the special goes out September 13th and
14th yes and then on sale September 15th
you're going to be at the Vic Theater in
Chicago Illinois why don't you recording
it again December 2nd it's a Saturday
and if we sell that we'll move to the
first it's samuelcanocomedy.com and the
pre-sale code is no pressure p-r-e-s-h
which is the the network the network
that I do the pods on of course I have
the uh hey babe and taste buds if you
guys they've been on it I've got you
scheduled football yeah we're coming
back of course you guys were literally
like you might be my all-time favorite
guest oh thank you there was something
about like you guys I don't know you
just you just did it so well thank you
like like guess like okay what do I
gotta do you just like I mean you live
this well I mean we argued over
Bagel Bites I was like this is
yeah so I'm excited that you and DeRosa
going back and forth man there's nothing
better it's fantastic yeah well that's
how I feel about you guys all right we
love you buddy thank you so much what do
you got for him uh we're all over the
road are you garbage.com follow the
tickets that second show uh in Philly we
had another one at the Fillmore get
those tickets that's moving quick too we
appreciate the love Toronto third show I
think maybe a fourth show in Chicago get
those tickets gang we love you
gang come see us go see Mr Salvo Cano
he's on tour right now and get tickets
for that special we love you we'll see
you next week peace